funerals for the victims of wednesday's
artillery attack in the semi-autonomous
kurdish region
women and children are among the victims
when a multiple rocket hit a tourist
resort in zaho
the foreign minister has described the
assault as a tragedy
the information that we received is that
there was a bombing of this safe tourist
site artillery and this calm beautiful
tourist village was hit
iraq says turkish forces are responsible
and has summoned its charged affair and
ankara for consultation
it has also halted procedures to appoint
a new ambassador
angry protesters have tried to storm the
turkish consulate in baghdad
as well as visa offices in karbala and
basra
we call on the government to close the
turkish embassy and suspend all tyres
with turkey iraq must have the right to
take legal and military action
turkey's foreign ministry has denied
responsibility
suggesting the attack was an act of
terrorism
the government has opened an
investigation into the incident but
these protesters want turkey to switch
its military operations away from iraq
turkish forces regularly carry out
airstrikes in the region
targeting members of the kurdistan
workers party or pkk
which it classifies as a terror group
ankara says it's willing to cooperate
with baghdad
as soon as the news broke we liaised
with the relevant institutions and
shared information according to the
information we've received from the
turkish armed forces we did not carry
out any attack against civilians we
believe the pkk terrorist organisation
is responsible
the area is only a few kilometers from
the turkish border
it has been declared military soon since
the attack
iraq wants to approach the un security
council saying it's a violation of its
sovereignty and threat to national
security turkey is waiting for the
investigation to conclude
and victims families are waiting for
justice
mahmoud
al jazeera
baghdad